[Music]
foreign
[Music]
how much
250 dollars no
and when the book is finished 500 more
I'm so proud of you
oh [ __ ] a bit of inspiration can go a
long way and movies have the gift to
inspire personal change giving
opportunity for Hope and resolutions
there are movies for getting in touch
with your inner hope and your roots
challenging oneself to push forward in
life picking up new skills and
rekindling determination are other ways
of inspiration played out in films as
well and some movies guide us through
trauma and disaster pushing characters
to their lowest point only to overcome
the obstacles ahead of them do you have
any idea what it's like knowing my real
brother
and mother spent every day of their
lives looking for me
huh
every day my real brother screams my
name
can you imagine the pain they must be
and not knowing where I am
well let's be hopeful as we count down
the most inspiring movies all ranked by
Tomato Meter
[Music]
foreign
Remember the Titans
in Virginia High School football is a
way of life each game celebrated more
lavishly than Christmas each playoff
distinguished more grandly than any
national holiday and with such
recognition Khan's powerful emotions in
1971 High School Football was everything
to the people of Alexandria but when the
local school board was forced to
integrate an all-black school with an
all-white School the very Foundation of
football's great tradition was put to
the test starring Denzel Washington Will
Patton Wood Harris and directed by baz
yakin critics say an inspirational crowd
pleaser with a healthy dose of social
commentary Remember the Titans may be
predictable but it's also well crafted
and features terrific performances
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's it boys that's it
good season
[Applause]
congratulations coach
I know football
what you did with those boys
you were the right man for the job coach
your Hall of Fame in my book
Number Nine Lion
five-year-old suru gets lost on a train
which takes him thousands of miles
across India away from home and family
suru must learn to survive alone in
Calcutta before ultimately being adopted
by an Australian couple 25 years later
armed with only a handful of memories
his unwavering determination and a
revolutionary technology known as Google
Earth he sets out to find his lost
family and finally return to his first
home starring Dev Patel Rooney Mara
Nicole Kidman and directed by Garth
Davis critics say Lions undeniably
uplifting story and talented cast make
it a moving Journey that transcends the
typical cliches of its genre
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
number eight Life of Pi
after deciding to sell their zoo in
India and move to Canada Santosh and
Gita Patel board a freighter with their
sons and a few remaining animals tragedy
strikes when a terrible storm sinks the
ship leaving the Patel's teenage son Pai
as the only human Survivor however Pai
is not alone a fearsome Bengal tiger has
also found Refuge aboard the Lifeboat as
days turn into weeks and weeks drag into
months pie and the tiger must learn to
trust each other if both are to survive
starring siraj Sharma Irfan Khan taboo
and directed by Ang Lee critics say a 3D
adaptation of a supposedly unfilmable
book Ang Lee's Life of Pi achieves a
near impossible it's an astonishing
technical achievement that's also
emotionally rewarding
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
chef
after a controlling owner pushes him too
far Chef Carl Casper quits his position
at a prestigious Los Angeles restaurant
as he tries to figure out what his next
step should be he finds himself in Miami
Carl joins forces with his ex-wife best
friend and son to launch a food truck
business The Venture provides a chance
to reignite his passion for cooking as
well as his zest for life and love
starring Sophia Vergara John Leguizamo
Scarlett Johansson and John Favreau who
also directed the film critics say
Chef's charming cast and sharp funny
script add enough space to make this
feel-good comedy a flavor if familiar
treat you know about Twitter yeah
how does it work that's cool
it's cool that's how it works it's cool
you tweet on it it's not like texting no
you sign me up
so what do you want your username to be
Carl
you can't just put Carl holding us to
the app something
I'll call Casper
that's oral Casper
digging somebody took my name
[Applause]
at Chef girl Casper is that cool
at
chef
Carl okay so is this for sex
you I was ever doing this for no I'm not
doing it for that so remember something
bad I want to see what they wrote
good
hey you can't talk like that I don't
care if mommy's not around I want you
cursing around here
that review went viral
what does that mean it means it got
picked up and retweeted everywhere so
all these people have read the review
yeah
number six Wild
driven to the Edge by the loss of her
beloved mother the disillusion of her
marriage and a headlong dive into
self-destructive Behavior Cheryl makes a
decision to put her life back together
again with no Outdoors experience a
heavy backpack and little else to go on
but her own will Cheryl sits out alone
to hike the Pacific Crest Trail one of
the country's longest and toughest
Trails starring Reese Witherspoon Laura
Dern Thomas sadoski and directed by
jean-mark valet critics say powerfully
moving and emotionally resonant wild
finds director jean-mark valet and star
Reese Witherspoon working at the peak of
their respective powers
we need to do a little pruning
okay so I'm gonna pick out the stuff
that's useless to you and you can leave
it in the free box unless you can give
me a good reason why you need it with
you okay okay
how's this working for you
I stink I stink all the time and my
armpits are the least of it
are you having much fun with these I've
never used them once
yeah I don't know what I was thinking
with the saw
you're burning what you read you want me
to burn books no you're not going to
become a Nazi I promise you but you are
going to make your pack a lot lighter
okay so everything before Kennedy
Meadows
oh wait not those
these will never be burned
it's your weight
number five Britney runs a marathon
a hard parting woman receives a
startling wake-up call when a visit to
the doctor reveals how unhealthy she is
motivated to lose weight she soon takes
up running to help her prepare for her
ultimate goal competing in the New York
City marathon starring Julian Bell
utkarsh and budkar Michaela Watkins and
directed by Paul Downes collazio critics
say Britney runs a marathon is an
Earnest and hilarious dramedy that
finally gives Jillian Bell a role worthy
of her gifts we have a bunch of
membership options to fit all your
Fitness needs with rates as low as 129
dollars a month I'm sorry I thought you
said
um as low and then the 129 for a month
yeah that's a starting rate 129 a month
and for that you get access to
everything in the gym except half of it
that's so every person we've walked by
has a hundred and twenty nine dollars to
just get to you is there a sliding skill
for people in debt up to their jobs
yeah
uh okay you do know that people can go
outside though and just be outside and
like do things absolutely and that's the
same Fitness experience you pay for our
facilities but going for a run outside
that is zero and then this one is what
is it again
Number Four The Shawshank Redemption
Andy Dufresne is sentenced to two
consecutive life terms in prison for the
murders of his wife and her lover and is
sentenced to a tough prison however only
Andy knows he didn't commit the crimes
while there he forms a friendship with
red experiences brutality of prison life
adapts helps the warden all in 19 years
starring Tim Robbins Morgan Freeman Bob
gunton and directed by Frank darabon
critics say the Shawshank Redemption is
an uplifting deeply satisfying prison
drama with sensitive Direction and fine
performances
in here I'm the guy who can get things
for you sure but
outside all you need is the Yellow Pages
hell I wouldn't even know where to begin
[Music]
Pacific Ocean
you might scare me to death something
that'd be not me
I didn't shoot my wife and I didn't
shoot her lover
whatever mistakes I've made I paid for
them and then so
I don't tell that book
I don't think that's too much to ask
I don't think you ought to be doing this
to yourself Andy it's just shitty pipe
dreams
I mean Mexico is way to hell down there
and you're in here and that's the way it
is
yeah right that's the way it is
it's down there and I'm in here
I guess it comes down to a simple Choice
really
get busy living
don't get busy die
number three Rocky
Rocky Balboa a small time boxer from
working class Philadelphia is
arbitrarily chosen to take on the
reigning world heavyweight champion
Apollo Creed while training with feisty
former bantamweight Contender Mickey
gold Mill Rocky tentatively begins a
relationship with Adrian the Wallflower
sister of his meat Packer Pali starring
Sylvester Stallone Burgess Meredith Carl
Weathers and directed by John G avalson
critics say Rocky's story of a down on
his luck boxer is Thoroughly predictable
but Sylvester Stallone's script and
stunning performance in the title role
brush aside complains
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you're gonna kill him
number two hidden figures
Catherine Johnson Dorothy Vaughn and
Mary Jackson are three brilliant
African-American women at Nasa they
serve as the brains behind one of the
greatest operations in history the
launch of Astronaut John Glenn into
orbit this is a stunning achievement
that restored the nation's confidence
turned around the space race and
galvanized the world starring Taraji P
Henson Octavia Spencer Janelle Monae and
directed by Theodore melfy critics say
in heartwarming crowd-pleasing fashion
hidden figures celebrates overlooked and
crucial contributions from a pivotal
moment in American history Hampton High
School is a wide School Mrs Jackson
yes your Anna I'm aware of that Virginia
still a segregated state
your honor you of all people should
understand The Importance of Being first
how's that Mrs Jackson
well you were the first in your family
to serve in the armed forces U.S Navy
the first to attend University
what's the point I plan on being an
engineer at NASA
but I can't do that without taking them
classes at that all-white High School
I can't change the color of my skin
so I have no choice but to be the first
which I can't do without you sir
your honor out of all the cases you're
gonna hear today
which one is going to matter 100 years
from now
which one is going to make you the first
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the pursuit of happiness
life is a struggle for single father
Chris Gardner evicted from their
apartment he and his young son find
themselves alone with no place to go
even though Chris eventually lands a job
as an intern at a prestigious brokerage
firm the position pays no money the pair
must live in shelters and endure many
hardships but Chris refused to give in
to despair as he struggles to create a
better life for himself and his son
starring Will Smith Jaden Smith Tandy
Newton and directed by Gabrielle muccino
critics say Will Smith's heartfelt
performance elevates The Pursuit of
Happiness above near melodrama I thought
I'd uh wear a shirt today
um you know being the last day and all
thank you
I appreciate that
but uh
wear one tomorrow though okay
because tomorrow is going to be your
first day
if you'd like to work here as a broker
would you like that Chris
good we couldn't be happier
welcome
was it as easy as it looked no sir no
I'm sorry it wasn't
good luck Chris thank you thank you
thank you thank you
sir
oh Chris
I almost forgot
Forrest Gump
slow witted for his Gump has never
thought of himself as disadvantage and
thanks to his supportive mother he leads
anything but a restricted life whether
dominating on the Gridiron as a college
football star fighting in Vietnam or
captaining a shrimp boat Force inspires
people with his childlike optimism but
one person for his cares about most may
be the most difficult to save his
childhood love the sweet but troubled
Jenny starring Tom Hanks Robin Wright
Gary Sinise and directed by Robert
zemeckis critics say Forrest Gump may be
an overly sentimental film with a
somewhat problematic message but its
sweetness and charm are usually enough
to approximate true depth and Grace
hey dummy
are you proud of just playing stupid I'm
sorry can't just run away for us
surprise
me here we go get you
run for
run [ __ ] you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Julie and Julia
frustrated with a soul-killing job New
Yorker Julie Powell embarks on a daring
project she vows to prepare all 524
recipes in Julia Child's Landmark
cookbook mastering the art of French
cooking intertwine with Julie's story is
the true tale of how Julia Child herself
conquered French cuisine with passion
fearlessness and plenty of butter
starring Meryl Streep Amy Adams Stanley
Tucci and directed by Nora Efren critics
say boosted by Meryl Streep's
charismatic performance as Julia Child
Julie and Julia is a light but fairly
entertaining culinary comedy
dear Avis I'm in my third week at The
Cordon blur and I'm in utter Bliss every
morning the alarm goes off at 6 30 like
leap out of bed
by 7 30 I'm in class in my apron peeling
potatoes then we cook stock Bone Fish we
dress pigeons we make pastry with so
much butter it almost stops your heart
just to look at it
teacher moves so quickly I'm sometimes
lost but I'm way ahead of the others in
the class more than men and all of them
very unfriendly until they discovered I
was Fearless something I realized but at
the same time they did
and finally number one Goodwill Hunting
Will Hunting has a genius level IQ but
chooses to work as a janitor at MIT when
he solves a difficult graduate level
math problem his talents are discovered
by Professor Gerald Lambo who decides to
help the misguided youth reach his
potential when will is arrested for
attacking a police officer Professor
Lambeau makes a deal to get leniency for
him if he will get treatment from
therapist Sean McGuire starring Matt
Damon Robin Williams Ben Affleck and
directed by Gus Van Sant critics say it
follows a predictable narrative Arc but
Goodwill Hunting adds enough quirks to
the journey and is loaded with enough
powerful performances that it remains in
entertaining emotionally Rich drama so
how's your lady
as she's gone
gone wet
med school medical school in California
really yeah what was this it's like a
week ago
that sucks
so uh when are you done with those
meetings
I think the week after I'm 21. yeah
they're gonna hook you up with a job or
what
yeah [ __ ] sit in a room and do long
division for the next 50 years
probably make some nice Bank though it's
gonna be a [ __ ] lab rat in this [ __ ]
way out of here
I want a way out of here for I mean I'm
gonna [ __ ] live here the rest of my
life
you know I'll be neighbors you know
we'll have little kids [ __ ] taking a
little league together up fully failed
look you're my best friend so don't take
this the wrong way
20 years if you're still living here
coming over my house watching the
Patriots game still working in
construction I'll [ __ ] kill you well
friends that about does it for us be
sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you
[Music]